good evening everyone thank you very
much for coming I'm John Tierney welcome
to the Museum of sex Here I am I am here
to talk with Roy Baumeister at this
event thank you Reason magazine for
sponsoring this and thank you dan Gluck
for inviting us here I'm here to talk
with Roy Baumeister
my co-author of the book willpower and
we want to talk about about that subject
about New Year's resolutions and we
wanna also unveil like a strategy a
self-help strategy that as far as I know
is the only one to have been
field-tested in the Oval Office after
President Barack Obama read our work he
changed his daily routine to improve his
decision-making now I'm not saying he
made all the right decisions since then
I imagine there are some people here who
do not regard him as the Soliman of our
age but I want to assure you that if he
had not followed the strategy that Rory
and I developed the things today would
be much worse and I also want to assure
you that it was not used the strategy
was not used to develop the
healthcare.gov website now I realize
that there are probably many people here
who were tired of hearing exhortations
and lectures from self-improvement gurus
and believe me I feel your pain I have
read more bad self-help books than Oprah
and dr. Phil combined I mean that's what
got me into this collaboration with Rory
really it started indirectly for me
where I was at dinner one night with
Christopher Buckley the comic novelist
and we were talking about the deep
philosophical subject that always comes
up when writers get together which is
money and we decided that we needed more
of it and we were so jealous of the of
the mega sales of self-help books that
we decided to write one of our own and
it was a comic novel titled God is my
broker and we revealed the seven and a
half laws of spiritual and
financial growth there were these were
eternal truths like money is God's way
of saying thanks and and my favorite law
was as long as God knows the truth it
doesn't matter what you tell your
customers now now in writing this book I
went back through the history of the
self-help genre all the way from Ben
Franklin to the present and I noticed
this of curious trends if you went back
in the 19th century and the Victorians
the self-help books then emphasized
perseverance and hard work they had
Maxim's like genius is patience but then
when you moved into the modern era
you've got these books promising quick
fixes and self-esteem and the sort of
feel-good philosophy with a rhyming
slogan believe it achieve it you know
Deepak Chopra had something he called
the law of least effort and and and and
I'll quoted verbatim it said ultimately
you come to the state where you do
nothing and accomplish everything you
know I guess it worked for him but but
you know I to me it seemed there been
this weird backward evolution that the
old books were better than the new books
and I didn't know what to make of this
until I started writing a science column
for the New York Times and I can I met a
Roy Baumeister I heard he's one of the
most prolific social psychologists on
the planet and Roy got his start he was
one of the early leaders in the
researching the self esteem which showed
that people who are more confident
people people with more confidence in
themselves tend to be happier and more
successful but then Roy realized that
the researchers had it backwards that
self-esteem does not lead to success
rather success leads to self-esteem you
know winning the Nobel Prize will make
you feel good about yourself but but
feeling good about yourself will not get
you to Stockholm if it did Donald Trump
would be there every year
so Roy looked at dozens of personality
traits and he found that only one of
them predicted how well a student would
do in college and that trait it was not
self-esteem it was self-control and this
was something that had been kind of out
of fashion but more and more studies
started showing that no matter what kind
of successful outcome you looked at it
in school and in careers in marriages
and relationships financial security
health in general there were two
qualities that correlate with success
and one of them is intelligence the
other is self-control and so far
researchers haven't figured out what to
do about intelligence but they have
rediscovered how to improve self-control
and they have rediscovered the concept
of willpower which until Roy came along
scientists in the 20th century had had
looked down willpower is this kind of
quaint metaphor invented by uptight
Victorians you know Victorians thought
of the body like there was a steam
engine inside you and when you had some
terrible temptation like you know like
the sight of a bare ankle you just
powered up the steam engine and you went
and you took a cold shower and now the
Victorians were rather odd I don't think
they'd be really comfortable here at the
Museum of sex but Roy discovered that
they actually were correct I mean not
about everything he doesn't share their
ankle fetish but he discovered that they
were right about willpower and I like
why not to tell us why um
how that happened well we we started
doing experiment I first I surveyed the
the literature and I thought well this
could be that there that the willpower
where things seemed viable that there
was some energy at the time nobody in
psychology was using energy theories
everything was the brain is a little
computer and information processing is
all what it's about and it calculates
what you're supposed to do and then you
do it but we said well could this could
this still be true a lot of the data are
looking like there's a there's some
energy involved there so we started
doing these laboratory experiments and
sure enough after you know we'd have
people first control their thoughts you
know tell them not to think about
something and then measure their
physical stamina and their physical
stamina was worse that trying to control
their thoughts and shut
Annoying thought out of their mind had
actually you taken something out of them
or we had them watch a funny comedy and
try to keep a poker face don't laugh and
that that took something out of them and
then they would do we're son on another
test of self-control one of the biggest
ones was we had people resist temptation
to eat we had agreed to contrive this
for a while we you can't tell people and
in psychology what you're gonna study
about them because it makes them all
weird if we tell them we're gonna test
yourself control you can imagine by the
time they got to the laboratory they'd
be all shaking and suspicious and so on
so we told him we're just gonna study
how well people can remember certain
tastes so they come in and and then my
colleagues came up with this clever
thing or we had set up a microwave oven
and baked chocolate chip cookies you
know microwave blows out the scent so
really smells awfully good and we told
him to skip lunch you know before the
experiment so their taste buds would be
fresh so they're hungry and then they're
all smelling these chocolates and
cookies and no hungry friends we sit him
down at a table and there's a stack of
these cookies and chocolate candies like
no and also there there's a bowl of
radishes and for the crucial condition
we said well you've been assigned to the
radish condition so we're gonna have you
eat radishes and don't touch the car
chocolate or cookies they're for other
people and to maximize the temptation we
left him alone for five minutes and of
course we didn't trust them so we
secretly observed and no they looked
like they were tempted they're longingly
glancing at the cookies but they're
knowing on this one puny little radish
and they're picking up the cookies and
smelling them and putting him back but
anyway they are managed nobody actually
bit into the forbidden food and they all
managed to eat the better part of a
radish we had others who we told go
ahead and eat the chocolates and we also
had some with no food but the ones we
interested in the ones who had to sit
there
seeing those chocolates and smelling
those chocolates and whining those
talking about instead of making some
people stupid radishes so have a few
minutes they resist a temptation that we
took them into a another room and by a
procedure from stress researchers how
long do people keep trying at a
difficult puzzle before they give up
and sure enough they quit way faster if
they'd been in the radish condition that
the resisting the temptation to eat
those cookies had taken something out of
them that then they didn't have enough
to make themselves keep trying and keep
going and keep struggling to solve that
difficult puzzle so anyway lots and lots
of these experiments suggest that yeah
there's some kind of energy that's
that's used up and then because John
said the old folk notion of willpower I
has some truth to it that the mind is
not just a computer
although computers run on energy too
although nobody was was talking about
that in psychology but rather there
there are some energy processes and some
things take take more than others so
that was a crucial step forward so after
you discovered the willpower was this
this kind of mental energy there were a
couple questions that came up one was
how do you what is the source of this
energy okay well it emerged over time
that seems to be tied into the body's
basic energy supply there's chemical
called glucose in your bloodstream know
that carries energy from the stores it's
makes fuel for the brain for the brain
cells to fire also powers your muscles
and and other things like that and
nutritionists had collected a lot of
data over the time without much of a
theory that when people's blood sugar
gets low and they don't have that much
glucose their self-control breaks down
diabetics who actually have a
fluctuating sometimes they're very high
blood sugar but it doesn't do them any
good because their body isn't using it
you know the day of self-control
problems also studies of like juvenile
delinquents and in other people they
seem to have blood blood sugar issues
they're experimentally test things like
they'll have to tell a whole class of
kids to not have breakfast one day so
all the kids come and nobody's eating
anything they randomly assign half the
kids to get breakfast and half to not
get any breakfast and then they see what
happens and sure enough the ones who
didn't get any food they learn worse and
they behave
until 10 o'clock when everybody gets a
snack and then all the differences
disappear there's even a study with
judges I didn't get into the
decision-making thing yet but it turns
out making decisions also draws on the
same energy so after you make a lot of
choices your will powers down I
surprised politicians haven't started
using this as an excuse for all the sex
scandals and stuff well I'm making a lot
of difficult decisions you know uses a
but you know it would be valid we do get
that that kind of effect in there anyway
there's a study with the Israeli parole
judges it looks at you know do they do
the easy thing and just send them right
back or do they actually let the the
ones who've paid their debt and earned
it to be paroled and go out in society
well turns out first one comes up in the
morning it's a very good chance of
getting parole but the judges are making
these decisions all day long and it's a
lot of information a lot of weeks kind
of grueling and so the likelihood that
the guy will get paroled just goes down
down down as the day goes on until
actually mid morning they have a break
and they get a snack and they get an
apple and so forth and then suddenly the
next guy is a good chance of getting
paroled again and then it goes down down
down until just before lunch is like a
ten or fifteen percent chance of getting
paroled where's the first one after
lunch he has like two-thirds chance of
getting in so if you ever in this
situation which I hope you're not and
you're they say well we can take one
more before lunch say no no I'll wait
till after lunch because it really makes
a big difference
there's a phrase lawyers use that
justice is what the what the judge had
for breakfast but it appears breakfast
snack and lunch all have a significant
impact into the the decision making
process there so it is tied into the
energy supply when the immune system for
example uses a lot I know they're a lot
of colds and things going around if
you've been exposed to something like
that your body immune system takes a lot
of energy to fight off the cold in that
case your decisions will be worse your
self-control will be worse it's part you
know it's just a natural process there's
nothing wrong with you just you got to
understand the body has a certain
economy of how it uses its energy of
resisting temptation or
behaving properly or not saying
something unkind you know that's one of
its priorities but fighting disease is a
higher priority and so there'll be less
left over for it at that time
so this discovery by Rory's have
willpower and and the fact that it can
be depleted he named it ego depletion
which he borrowed the term from Freud
that the the part of your mind that
controls your impulses and and so you go
to police and you know sets in on on
everyone basically the same way those
judges became depleted as a day wore on
and couldn't make a decision it's been
documented lots of studies where they've
looked at it choppers in malls and they
find that people have done the more
shopping have less self-control later
they've done some really interesting
real world studies were they with car
buyers where they start out someone who
buys a car and he has to make it has to
go down this list of options about what
kind of engine you might have 13
different kinds of engines and in 200
different you know colors for the
interior is it taupe or camel or ivory
there's so many shades of brown and what
they find is that people will start
trying to make the decision but as they
go down the list they just give up and
they start taking the default option and
the researchers experimented with that
and they and they varied the order of
the decisions sometimes they put the
expensive decisions like the engine
first sometimes they put the the
expensive decisions last and then it
made a huge difference on what people
chose about $2,000 per car and and so
the standard option is often one of the
more expensive ones all right all right
the people go and just take whatever
standard as they get as their willpower
gets used up and they don't want to
think about and make any more choices
they'll just say okay I'll just take
whatever standard and that can cost you
yeah so our take is that all of us who
really like those car buyers today
because we're just bombarded by
decisions and in temptations all day
long the modern world really offers you
a lot more than there ever were before
once they wake up the president Obama
thing you mentioned earlier after he
read The Times coverage of our stuff he
said well
just going to wear blue and gray suits
from now on I don't to make spend any
energy deciding what to wear or what to
eat right and so make no more decisions
that was his his reaction which is a
good strategy to do that because some
more research of Roy ash and some
researchers in Germany and the
Netherlands they've tracked people all
day long and ask them what they're
experiencing at any one moment and they
found that the typical person during a
day spends between three and four hours
resisting desires basically just you
know you know the desire to eat the
desire to on it your boss the desire to
you know just having to exert
self-control and then and that didn't
even know I count all the decisions they
have to make which is even right yeah
yeah yeah so you're basically being
depleted all day long and so we've I
mean willpower we talked about the
findings behind this and we also just to
give you help with the New Year's
resolutions what we promise to do I'll
sort of break down the the summarize
this in the great spirit of self-help
books you have to have numbered laws you
know that and I'm gonna do better than
seven and a half I'm gonna do eight so
here are eight strategies for the New
Year's resolution which is number one
which is know your limits that basically
what I've just been saying that that you
only have a finite amount of willpower
and the more you use it it gets depleted
so you know as far as New Year's
resolution the first thing to know about
that is don't make more than one because
if you make more than one they're
competing against each other can I add
yeah when this is exactly right if
people make a list of New Year's
resolutions and every time you work on
one it uses up some willpower and takes
away your ability to work on others I
don't say don't make new year's
resolutions okay but do them
sequentially rather than all at once
pick the easiest one and do that first
and because you can actually strengthen
your willpower by following through and
doing and succeeding at and so start to
start with the easy one but yeah one at
a time right and there's no obvious sign
you know wearing other researchers
looked for what does it feel like when
you're
suffering from ego depletion when your
willpower is low and what's the answer
to that there's no particular signature
feeling but everything strikes you a
little bit more intensively you desire
things more you react more strongly and
so on so when your your will powers down
you'll just feel things more strongly
things start bothering you more than
they should
it could be a sign you're getting sick
because again that takes that uses up
some of your glucose because you've lost
the capacity to control you're really
yeah people are often damping down their
reactions it's part I think of how we
live in a civilized society is we kind
of keep all our desires and feelings and
nasty sexual museum types in a check
okay nice ones too but particularly the
nasty ones have to be kept in so they'll
emerge a little more strongly when
you're your central self control is is
weakened okay so the second strategy is
to build your willpower and our world
likes to use the analogy but I will
power being like a muscle do you want to
explain that well sure I like a muscle I
mean the depletion effect is like a
muscle when you exercise it exerted it
gets tired for a while but if you
exercise regularly it will get stronger
and there at least a dozen published
studies often very impressive results
that show of having people do
self-control exercises for two or three
weeks can improve their capacity to do
things quite different from what they
exercise that you know the bringing will
give them lab tests of self-control that
had nothing to do with the exercises
they were doing but there's one muscle
for self-control and it's one resource
that you use the same willpower for
everything it's limited so people use it
for one thing not others but making it
you're exercising it will make it
stronger and that will help you tackle
whatever other challenges you decide to
apply it to and the kind of exercise I
mean and the experiments they did one
where they just sent students home and
told them to work on their posture the
next two week and whenever you you know
think of it just sit up straight stand
up straight
right and in some but to our surprise
then we brought them in and did
laboratory tests of stamina and mental
control things and they did they did
better on those things just from working
on their posture it did the old
Victorian idea of building character
that you exerting self-control is good
for you well it turns out they were
right about that too or at least there's
something to it that it it does
strengthen your character it makes you a
stronger person to exert self-control on
a regular basis and that's probably one
of the reasons that you know studies
have repeatedly shown that religious
people tend to have more self-control
than non-religious people now part of
that may be a selection bias it takes a
certain amount of self-control to go to
church and do that but but all religions
encourage these practices meditation
prayers fasting they encourage all these
exercises that basically build that
willpower muscle and you don't have to
be religious to do it but just
meditating builds up that now I'll move
on we I don't want to I want to open
this up for questions soon but I'll just
work through the strategy the number
three strategy is is the is the best one
eat you know that you have to eat to
have self-control I'd love to do that in
a place with food and this is what we
call the dieters catch-22 it's white
dieting people often think of dieting as
the ultimate you know example of
self-control it's an easy example to use
but of all the things the other Rory
have study searchers have studied
self-control correlates with success in
everything but when it comes to losing
weight the correlation is much weaker
than it is say with with academic stuff
and that's because of this complicated
reaction that if you starve yourself you
don't have self-control so it's a very
it's just catch-22 that in order to die
honor to have self-control you need to
eat but in order to lose weight you need
not to eat so it's very difficult so the
fourth strategy is to avoid the planning
fallacy which is this is something that
that I'm all of us tend to underestimate
how long something will take it's one of
the problems in making plans for the new
year and and one of our studies you
found that other people basically
underestimated how long it would take to
do a paper by about half
oh yes their number of studies like this
this this one where they asked students
what's the best case and your worst case
for how long it will take you to get
your thesis done and you know nobody
even finished by the worst case of the
best days Matt was off-the-charts
the only accurate predictions they got
in that study was sometimes they ask the
roommate how long do you think it's
gonna take the fifth strategy is to make
it to do list that's actually doable and
the problem most people have is that
they put stuff on to-do lists that it's
a vague thing like hire new sales rep
but you don't really know how to do that
you have to be yeah it has to be very
specific I'll just mention very quickly
one of my favorite findings in the book
which was about this a Garnica fact
which is this in effect discovered in
the 20s but by by Bluma Zeigarnik a
psychology student in berlin and she and
she went to do a restaurant with some
colleagues one day and the waiter took
their order and he didn't write anything
down his big group and he came back
served everybody perfectly they were
really impressed after lunch one of the
psychologists goes back because he's
forgotten something and he sees the
waiter and he asked them for help hoping
he'll benefit from this man's excellent
memory and the waiter just looks back at
him blankly he has no idea who the guy
is and he explains that once he delivers
an order it vanishes from his mind
so the psychologists start thinking is
there a big difference between finished
and unfinished tasks and they found
indeed that there is that the brain
keeps nagging at you at an unfinished
task now obviously when you've got you
know 200 emails and you've got phone
calls and all these things you can't
finish every task at once so stuff is
going to nag at you
but Roy found awareness laboratory where
you know to turn off that Sagarika fact
later yes if you make a very specific
plan for exactly what you're going to do
that seems to turn off the the nagging
effect a general plan like you know buy
a present for mother or something that
isn't there but you know go to the store
tomorrow at 3 these these intrusive
thoughts about the unfulfilled
unfinished business unfulfilled goals
the unconscious is bothering the
consciousness you not to get it done
necessarily but to give it something
very specific that it can watch for and
say okay when this happens then I'll
know to take the next step that's all
the unconscious needs and then it can
stop pestering you with those intrusive
thoughts that you haven't put away the
dirty dishes yet or the clean dishes the
dirty dishes a great guide for doing
that is about getting things done by
David Allen the GTD system problem sure
you know many people here know that but
I'm one of our favorite experiences
doing the book was we went and visited
David Allen and in California and it's
an amazing experience you go into his
office he's got about this big l-shaped
desk is about six feet on each side and
you look at it and it's 12 feet of naked
wood there's nothing in his inboxes
nothing on his desk that's his whole
system is you've got to get rid of stuff
you've got to basically get rid of the
Sagarika fake you've got a you know
everything that comes on his desk every
email he makes a plan to deal with it
he's got tickler files and you know and
the result is you've got a clean mind to
do what you can I mean David likes to
say that you know that if you need cat
food and you want to find God you have
to get the cat food first you know don't
so so and he's got lots of tips for
basically making a to-do list and
getting stuff done so it's very specific
now we're moving on here number six very
basic strategy but it's it it's
overlooked sometimes is it's not enough
just to set goals and resolution for the
new year you have to keep track that's
just fundamental to all exercise of
self-control is setting the goal and
keeping track if you want to spend less
money keep track with every week if you
want to lose weight weigh yourself every
day that's that's one of the few
clinically proven ways to leave waves
ironically for years the conventional
wisdom had been don't weigh yourself
every day because weight fluctuates and
it'll be discouraging and so on now
that's the one thing that they went
against we're saying because we thought
you're keeping track is better it's hard
to control something if you're not
keeping track of it but then I study
came out about two or just before we did
the book that said oh the people who
actually weigh themselves every day do
the best and keeping their weight down
and keeping control of it yes that's why
we
you know keeping track is kind of a bore
but the nice thing is that there are
lots of smartphone apps there's a
website called the quantified self that
has all these apps and gadgets that will
keep track of of what you do on your
computer I'll even you'll shut off the
web there's some apps the other will you
know send a note to your boss telling
you how much time you spend on on the
Museum of sex website and the reason
West hey if you want all these things
basically to to monitor you to in what
you spend your time on and you know how
many steps you take it everything so
just keeping track is a very basic thing
and it is easier not because there's a
lot of technology that will do it for
you the strategy number seven is what we
call the nothing alternative which is
named which we borrowed from Raymond
Chandler the great mystery writer he
managed to turn out masterpieces like
The Big Sleep
by following he would go into his office
every day for four hours and he would
follow to you two rules a you don't have
to write be you can't do anything else
and his idea was that eventually you're
gonna get so bored you'll do the work
and that's and and so I think that's a
great strategy for anyone to say take
the first 90 minutes of your day
open the the smart wats the smartphone
app for you know you know first
stopwatch and don't do anything apart
from your primary project that they no
phone calls no no web stuff only stuff
that's related to your primary project
and and in that one I'm done to strategy
number eight the final one and this is
really the most important one because
it's conserve your willpower visitor to
say buy our book that's the a thing they
have the this is one the President Obama
was doing and and it and this flows I
mean it from another study that Roy did
with with some colleagues that surprised
them because they were tracking people
all day long
in other words just a reminder but
though that and they found that and they
were looking to it for the correlation
between people who had best self-control
and how often they exercise self-control
and they expected that the people you
know with the best self-control would be
using it all day long because they were
so strong but they found the opposite
right you know significant the other way
that people with high self-control
actually spend less time resisting
temptations and desires and so well how
could that be but they stay out of
trouble now we call this in the book
playing offense not defense a lot of
people think self-control is something
you use in the moment of crisis and a
heat of temptation or whatever that
that's when you call on it well the
people with good self-control plan not
to be exposed to temptation they set up
their lives to run smoothly and then
they don't have these problems in it
that actually works it works way better
right it is a kind of thing where I mean
what Obama was doing basically was
outsourcing his self-control his
decisions to someone else and that we
don't all have the kind of staff he does
someone else to choose your food for you
but you can outsource instead of
deciding every morning whether to
exercise or not you can just set up an
appointment with a friend so you
basically outsource that you know that's
self control you don't have to make
yourself do it and and you can outsource
a lot of this stuff you know to
computers it will let you want to do
things
friends will do it Facebook groups that
kind of thing there's a huge benefit
between good self-control and success in
work in school
you think about what do you need
willpower for there is it for staying up
all night to get the paper done or the
presentation for the next date well I
suppose that that does take it but
that's not what people with good
self-control do they start early and get
it done
ahead of time so they don't have to
spend the night before the deadline
staying up all night now I used to hate
to hear this because I've been a
procrastinator all my life I don't have
ever turned in a New York Times column
ahead of time you know usually after the
deadline and I never turn in college
papers on time when I started work with
Roy and started doing these these
strategies we actually turned in the
book two months ahead of time
our editor is still not recovered from
the shock of it I think the writers
union wanted to break our hands you know
so so I can't tell you that the
strategies do work and and and we glad
to take any more questions from your
film if you'd like yeah so when you're
talking about both preserving your
willpower and exercising it to grow it
what is the magnitude of different you
can expect from these as compared to the
magnitude we know genetics plays from
the separated twin literature all right
so you want an answer like in percent of
the variance or something like that I
mean I don't know quite how to answer I
can compare the you know the genetic
effects are mostly interactive with it
turns out pure genophix are fairly small
and most things maybe not with
intelligence but most other things it's
the interaction between the genes and
environment the pure environment effects
are even smaller but interactions
between them seem to be where the lion's
share the variance is I think with the
self-control we do find when we give
people these exercises the people who
start off with pretty good self-control
benefit more from the exercises but it's
probably because they do the exercises
more the other people say oh yeah I'll
do it but then they they don't go home
and they don't bother just work on their
posture or or not swear or whatever we
assign them to to do nonetheless
well here's one one way to put it one of
my former PhD students published a paper
about three years ago we try to get
people to quit smoking and that's one of
the hardest I mean quitting smoking is
the graveyard of psychological theories
nothing works
but he had a bunch of people and had
them do exercises for several weeks of
regulating your resisting their desires
and you know being good and stuff like
that so I had nothing to do with smoking
you just build up their willpower with
sort of simple self control exercises
and then had them try to quit smoking
and a triple the success rate which went
like from 5% to 15% it's not like 90% of
them suddenly we're but but still 5% to
15 that that's that's a huge effect
there
hello I'm Stanton peel and in four weeks
I'm going to be appearing here with John
and Sally Satele talking about addiction
John I was really curious when you began
you talked about how we've gone downhill
in terms of our views of self-help
because early in an earlier era we were
more willing to recognize self-control
and now that's almost a negative concept
that you have to market against so I was
going to ask you why you think that is
and before I get your answer I want to
propose why I think that is I think your
marketing against the entire addiction
model of powerlessness which comes both
from a a but also modern neuroscience
both of and the hijacked brain so how I
interpret your work in my most recent
book recover is that we've gone away
from something that makes a lot of
logical common sense because we've been
told that we're not able to exercise
self-control and I view the world as
being a kind of marketing of means and
you're coming back with an idea well
willpower and self-control everybody
knows from history they make sense
how come we've discarded them do you
where do you see our loss of that idea
coming from we can both talk about this
I mean I I think part of it is that it's
just it's more fun to market things that
here's an easy way to do it that's you
know the power of positive thinking that
if you just you know I mean Napoleon
Hill and I would read these old books I
just couldn't you know believe this
stuff that Napoleon Hill had he's sold
just countless maybe they're it's still
being sold today this you know
tens of millions of books and his he had
a strategy where if you wanted to make
money you first had to think exactly how
much money you wanted then write it down
on a piece of paper and then every day
pick up that piece of paper and look at
it and that's how you got it you know I
mean I mean I can understand why people
like to believe that kind of stuff it's
maybe it's a religious belief it's a lot
easier and you know actually going to
work so I meant there was also I think I
mean one reason just historical was the
triumph of the well the Nazi acumen try
that when Hitler is doing your it's kind
of is the spokesman for willpower it's
not that's not good for your brand oh
well I have to say I've been much
influenced by your writings on the topic
and appreciate the chance to meet you
but very much right on the among other
points the the people who are addicted
they they like the idea that it's it's
beyond their control and that it's a
hopeless thing so that the victim
mentality really appealed to both the
the addicts and to the the you know the
medical for-profit establishment that
treats them the idea that well it just
takes willpower to resist it that's you
know that's not nearly as appealing so
and then there's you know the bias of
what they study you know most people who
ever smoked have quit smoking but they
did it on their own only a minority have
done it in these professional programs
and I think the way to the evidence
starting to show that the people who
quit a do have trouble quitting
addictions who are in these programs
they often have multiple psychological
problems and so they are kind of
hopeless cases but it's a huge mistake
to treat them as the norm it's a bit
like the old idea that homosexuals are
neurotic and then that psychology
embraced that for a long time but you
know they were dealing with people in
therapy who had often multiple problems
the other homosexuals came forward to
say well we're not neurotic we're
healthy and we want to be recognized as
such but that's not gonna happen with
addiction because all the addicts
benefit from the idea that it's be it's
out of their power
I mean there's the a a philosophy has a
built-in contradiction when it says well
you can't do it you need to surrender to
a higher power but meanwhile you better
get busy and do all these these other
things and actually quit yourself so you
know the higher power is not swatting
the beer bottle away you're actually
doing it yourself do I see myself that
way
well our book didn't really address
addiction or tackle it on but in a whole
chapter my subsequent work and think
about it I guess I've read a lot more
since then and so yes I I think the
weight of the evidence just doesn't
sustain the idea that the diction is
something that's out of your control I
mean again to go back to the alcohol
thing that the beer doesn't pour itself
down your throat the cigarette doesn't
light itself and but in your mouth
people are really voluntarily
cooperating to ingest these substances
it's it goes with all these things about
giving yourself permission and allowing
yourself to do it and taking a short
term instead of a long term focus all
these things really play into addiction
and sustained addiction and that's
that's I think what contributes and so
when people tell themselves well I can't
really help that I'm addicted they give
themselves excuses and in that way that
contributes to to making it worse
what's the connection between people
that commit crimes and a lack of
willpower if any and is are there any
implications for like how to fight
recidivism way back when I started
writing my first scholarly book on
self-control around 1990 I was reading
literature and right then a book came
out called a general theory of crime I
was struck by that because it was by
criminologist not by psychologists I
want to know what are they going to talk
about poverty or relative deprivation or
disadvantaged youth or whatever and they
said low self-control was the key to
understand it and okay that's that's
quite striking obviously after that bold
statement came out there was a flood of
research in criminology trying to test
and see whether that's true and that has
continued to hold up it's been confirmed
over and over again that yes I mean
there are lots of kinds of evidence
going back to the original thing
criminals the act of committing the
crime certainly is a sign of low self
control criminals don't specialize like
they do in the movies where they're less
just like any other professional they
tend to get arrested over and over again
for different crimes it's just an
impulsive lifestyle others have looked
at what criminals do on legal things and
they're they show low self-control -
criminals are more likely to smoke
cigarettes to be late for work if they
have jobs to be involved in unplanned
pregnancies and traffic accidents and
all sorts of things it's just sort of a
general screw-up lifestyle that that
contributes to it so that appears to be
true in fact the paper just came across
my desk today linking low self-control
to a variety of minor public
misbehaviors including drunk-dialing
binge drinking there's academic fraud is
a bit more serious even adults public
flatulence is associated that's
John and I prefer to speak to audiences
with higher self-control so so that is
to know my colleague Jim tang nee has
been doing research in prisons with if
we developed a trade scale to measure
self-control you said it is a huge
predictor of recidivism that that
prisoners will have higher self control
within the range they have are less
likely to be re-arrested when they leave
and if they can bolster and train them
in self-control in some ways it really
reduces their chances of being really
probably also know going to the
nutrition and glucose thing criminals
tend to eat very bad diets
I initially read one of the memoirs of
the gang wars so I had another book on
evil and violence I remember reading a
guy said man when we were in gang wars I
remember started feeling really bad and
I wondered if it was all the junk food
as it turns out when they're in the
middle of a gang war they don't go home
at 6 o'clock and have a nice healthy
meal with leafy vegetables in and greens
and stuff like that they they stop at
fast-food places and eat junk food and
stuff and that's you think bad for your
glucose overtime they've done systematic
studies in prisons where they'll take
the the diet and improve it you know for
half the population and not the others
and the the ones who you know take the
vitamin supplements and eat vegetables
they're their disciplinary problems in
prison drop by half as long as a study
and then it says the studies over then
they go back to getting in trouble again
so now diet training self control all
those things are really useful in
combating crime and it continues to be I
guess they won't say it's it's the key
anymore you know things in social
science get more complicated over time
but it's still a major key and probably
the biggest single predictor of
criminality it's also gone the other way
and that they there's a huge study in
New Zealand where they track kids for
decades and they had a lot of measures
of self-control and they were young by
their teachers their parents and tests
and they found that it did it predicted
bad outcomes and everything in a much
and it did predict your likelihood of
being in jail basically yeah yeah how
well a kid did it self control at age 10
predicted whether he'd have been
arrested by by age 30 a question in the
right corner over here do you draw any
distinction hi
do you draw any distinction between
discipline and obeying rules and
self-control and also do you find that
the positive effects have sort of a
diminishing ultimately diminish for
people who are you know particularly
persnickety or neurotic or anal just by
nature and their personality couple of
key points Oh self-control is a broader
term than discipline but a discipline is
certainly an important instance of it
and following rules and it's it's one of
the things we evolved to do it's it's
what makes humans separate from others
as we're able to create civilization but
civilization only works if most people
follow most of the rules most of the
time so that capacity to do it sometimes
a lecture on human nature I'd say well
if we hired a gorilla and gave him a job
and a in a car in an apartment it's on
why would that work but you can't
consistently obey the rules enough to to
sustain civilized society now the other
question diminishing returns
we've looked looked for that when it
turns out there there is such a thing as
say the over controlled child but that
that's not an excess of self-control
that's it's basically a fearful outlook
from being overly and inhibited or
something like that when we test
self-control I told you tang and I
developed this scale to measure it and
we thought it would be really cool if we
could show that it goes up and up in
terms of the benefits and then at the
high levels turns down and we beat the
statistics every which way to try to get
that downturn and we just not could find
it I could not find it it seemed like as
far as within the normal range the more
self-control you have the better and you
can put it to bad things and there are
traits as you say like being anal and
and someone but the people who have
these compulsive traits and so on
they're not highly self-control in fact
they say I'm lacking self-control they
see their their indulgence they're sort
of trying these other things as a way to
try to reestablish some some some
control so
is not an excess of self-control I think
the self-control like intelligence it's
a tool you can use it for bad things but
basically the more you have the better
okay this is really helpful because I
think it explains but I want to add that
an approach that I've been developing
that works and doesn't seem like it
should make sense so the first thing is
the difference between affirmative
statements and I guess what are now
called interrogative self self
interrogative statements so like you get
up in the morning and instead of saying
I will exercise today if you say will I
exercise today you're more likely to
exercise and do you know what I'm
talking about which one is more likely
to ask you know if a firm ative
statement let your self conscious sort
of off the hook
yeah I've committed to exercising so I
don't have to worry about it and then
you're going to bed you say damn I
forgot to exercise whereas if you keep
asking yourself will I exercise the only
way of answering that is by exercising
right so that's the first thing so I use
those two I mean there's a lot of
research recently on this so I use those
two so then the first case when I don't
want to do something I say I'll do it so
then I just forget about and like you
say that and and the other thing is you
say when you put the thing that's not
really doable on the list
it sort of nags you but there but the
corollary to that is if you can get if
you can not be nagged by it you don't
have to do it alright so I put all these
things on the list that my wife wants
done and it's on the list and then I
don't do it does that make any sense
so mmm you look confused so
and there's a wonderful thing called
them this is a guy out at Stanford I
can't remember his name
Perry I think it was his name he wrote a
thing called structured procrastination
procrastination shouts your professor
and wonder what you think of that
because that certainly works for me
structured procrastination I like to
call it the power of positive
procrastination which is the you know
the way to get you you know stay to
clean your closet out is to is to put at
the top of your list do taxes and so
you'll to avoid doing taxes you'll clean
your closet and you basically and and
and they're funny stories about and the
guy who does this very funny me he says
you know I accomplished all this stuff
because he just has these impossible
things at the top of the list so to
avoid doing them he'll do the other
stuff so and I mean there actually is
something to be said for you know if
you're you know if you're stuck on
something just you know you clean I mean
it softens it freelance writers have the
cleanest houses around do anything
rather than then you know then right so
but but I think that with the Sagarika
fact you just end up being the NAG by it
all the time it's just so much better to
you know just say I'm gonna do it for 90
minutes whatever happens happens but I
won't do anything else and then you're
free the rest of the day yeah we've
skipped over a couple of times children
discipline and impulsivity which
connecting those dots I got to ADHD and
you know I key characteristic of ADHD is
impulsivity which seems to be remarkably
controlled by these medications does
that mean that these medications also
somehow increase willpower I don't know
how those medications work and I don't I
know that we know as I do have you met
willpower neurologically because what
they say is the medications work by
stimulating your prefrontal cortex which
is where your higher management function
does and presumably where your willpower
it
yes yeah I'm not a brain person but I
have a bunch of colleagues who have done
that kind of work and you know in broad
terms yes you're right the front of the
brain is more the control part of the
back is the wanting and urging part but
exactly how self-control works there
that's been surprisingly difficult for
them to get that mapped and you know
ascertain exactly what happens with
depletion they're just some new studies
coming out in the last couple years
starting to show you know which which
regions work with it but you know to go
from there then to the the drug
operation that's another big step so if
you're looking for a way to increase
willpower the idea I mean it's appealing
but think I can just take a pill and
then I'll I'll be great willpower but I
wouldn't bet on there's more wondering
whether kids with ADHD are doomed to to
poor willpower but they do have great
focus that when it comes to I mean
especially you know entrepreneurs often
have ADHD and they're very focused on
one thing when they can do it so I mean
I wonder if the drugs are doing is
they're basically the effect of like
your computer shutting you off the web
it is not letting certain stimuli come
through and in letting you focus and
what I mean this is a very crude you
know my analogy for it but but there
have also been some brain studies trying
to look at I mean our experiments are
looking what actually at the physical
mechanics of self-control they've done
experiments where they give people a
glass of lemonade either with Splenda or
sugar and and you do the sugar not
because it's a great thing for you
because it works very quickly and when
in a glass of lemonade will improve your
willpower right away that people have
more but it doesn't work if there is not
sugar in it because you want their
glucose and their Benson brain studies
not whether they're trying to see what
happens when that sugar goes in actually
right and indicee yes it does seem to
reverse some of the patterns
show up when people are depleted but can
brain research as is missing it at
present a very imprecise so our next
guest here at the next session is Salas
the Talos but pretty skeptical the brain
stuff done so ok good hi I was wondering
if you would speculate on our
evolutionary history so that our
ancestors probably wouldn't have a
problem with willpower if they were
getting attacked by a tiger they'd know
what to do so I wonder how much of this
is a mismatch with just things that are
evolutionarily familiar versus things
that are evolutionarily novel so taxes
is something completely novel so would
you speculate on how general willpower
might have come about all right I think
first of all we think we don't have that
much willpower but we have more than
other species the glass is half full and
half empty we can all imagine life would
be better if we had better self-control
than we do but as I said the kind of
civilized society that we create we
don't see other other creatures being
able to do that you have to behave that
like that flexibly and understand
complex hierarchies of rules and so
forth so the key to human evolution was
learning to work together socially and
in these new systems particularly to
reach beyond the the kin group and the
basic genetic selfishness that produces
what limited cooperation there is in
other species so you need to control
your behavior need to subdue impulses to
go along and comply with the rules of
the group and as I think these would be
have co-evolved as we do our ancestors
developed better self control for
managing selves they were able to
construct more complicated social
systems that were then more effective
and so the
in time the groups with the more
effective social systems were able to
suppliant and defeat their their rivals
who didn't have as much I mean they're
examples people you know point out just
in primates having some self I mean dogs
have self-control
there been experiments where you can do
ego depletion was a dog if he obeys a
commits a stay or sit command for ten
minutes and then you give them the doggy
version of a puzzle to do the dogs that
have to obey the stay command for 10
minutes quit sooner than the dogs that
were just relaxing inside a cage and and
they can also be reversed with lemonade
if you're with sugar and there's some
thought that the self-control evolved in
very basic sense that in a group of the
if there's an alpha male who gets to eat
first that the others have to exert
self-control to not eat that food that's
there because if they don't then the
group's going to spend all its energy
fighting and they're not going to
survive and similarly people have
suggested that you know that our
civilization that ancient
hunter-gatherers who could get tubers
and not eat them right away when they
were poisonous would have the
self-control to basically put the beside
her and do that that all these things
basically were essential for survival
now I think your point though about that
there were somewhat miss maths is that
you know throughout a lot of history
there were fairly simple rules you know
and in the Middle Ages somebody didn't
you know have a lot of decisions all day
long you basically work did one job
you've got you know the the main
temptations were getting drunk which
wasn't really even that bad a thing most
people were trunkful much at the time
and you know an adultery but you know I
mean you weren't trying to decide what
kind of career to go into you had a very
clear code of conduct from that was
enforced by God in your mind by the
church by your neighbors and and the
reason the Victorians got so obsessed
with willpower is that they were
concerned about all these villagers
leaving their churches and their
communities where there was a social
control going into these cities and
suddenly you know people don't believe
in God anymore there's no church so they
really worry how can we have people
control themselves without feeling that
there's a church and a God doing it and
so that was really the whole idea that
we have to inculcate character
and I think it's gotten worse today
because we all have choices all day long
about every second it's your it's your
desk you can you know goof off where as
a peasant in the field didn't have a lot
of choices um so how easily or and how
precisely can self control be measured
is there a standard scale and induced in
a way that I can assess my own self
control I firstly there's no single gold
standard measurement in our experiments
we do the all these different behavioral
things to you know so we can compare one
group against another and say well this
group did worse than that group that
works but they're all indirect we do
have as I said their personality scales
the one that Jun tangy and I've
developed it's a series of questions but
if I think if you fill it out knowing
that this is measuring yourself control
that could weaken the validity of it
make you wanted to say oh yeah I'm
really good the questions then it
becomes obvious what their what they're
getting at so I I'm sorry to say the
short answer is no it's not an easy way
to test it you can yeah yeah maybe maybe
ask your wife or your roommate and I
mean experiments that yeah their
techniques like how long you can hold
your hand in ice water how long you can
squeeze a grip how long you work on a
puzzle that's not solvable those are
experimental ways to measure
perseverance but those are also I'm a
relative I mean the cold water bothers
some people more than others and so it
takes more self-control for some people
to do it than others
I had a question whether willpower is
just one element of self-control and
what the impact of identity or our
ideology would be and if you permit me
just a personal thing
so February is my clean month so
substance wise no weed no alcohol no
caffeine and especially on the alcohol
that's very difficult but because I do
it every year I know I'm Scott I Fabri
is my clean month I'm not tempted and
it's become very easy for me to do so I
don't rely on willpower if I relied on
willpower I would fall short I rely on
sort of an identity an ideology I was
wondering if you had any thoughts about
that well you're basically doing there
or the strategy we're talking about
conserving your willpower and one of the
ways to do that is is we call
bright-line rules that basically when
you have a very clear rule I mean that's
one of the reasons that not drink you
know that it's much easier to stop
drinking than than to lose weight
because you can have a rule a clear rule
I don't drink after six I don't drink at
all
I don't drink in February and that's
easy to do but you can't say I'm not
going to eat so it's it's not a
bright-line rule and and the more you
can do these rules that are very clear
and easy to follow so you know when
you've gone across it it gets easier and
then as you say once you establish a
rule it's hard to do it at first but
then once it becomes a habit it's not
really a decision you're making anymore
and then therefore you're not really
depleting your willpower to do it I like
the choice of February - it's the
shortest month you got
I want to ask one another question it
takes to his question and it takes it
there is a very common view that
willpower self-control isn't a matter of
your personal ability it's not that much
different from person to person it's
just a matter of how you manage it how
much would you say is willpower versus
the management of your willpower it all
depends if you've read our book or not I
think that's really a bet that's the two
basic groups you have I think yes I
would say they they're both important
there are real differences going back to
we're gonna Walter Mischel on those
marshmallow studies or the kids at age
four how they performed in a lab test of
being able to wait 10 minutes to to eat
the cookie or the marshmallow predicted
how well they did in college and how
later on how much money they made in
their careers so there is a there are
differences there but but using it
properly or misusing it that's a large
contributing factor as well
so yes some of those people who have
very messed-up lives could have you know
had the willpower to do better or maybe
had it but just devoted it in the wrong
things there's things like
overconfidence you're thinking you have
more willpower than you actually have
the study I liked where they they took
smokers and they said you want to bet on
yourself can you watch this movie
without smoking and well you can you can
have you can have there are different
levels of your one is cigarettes are in
the other room was it was a movie that
glorified smoking cigarettes in the
other room and that was like worth I
think they did in Europe so was three
euros if you could do that versus you
know have them on the table it be six
euros and the highest was you get 12
euros if you watch this movie holding an
unlit cigarette in your mouth now for it
so people's about 12 year olds oh yeah I
can do that none of them completed that
you know the ones who - I'll go for
three euros and leave it in the other
room so much lower coal John said gofer
reachable goals they were much more
successful at it so you know these were
the same people they were you know put
it two different there definitely
differences yes there are the
substantial differences but again it
sort of takes some self-control to
manage your self-control right so
whether they could have done better if
they had planned better and plotted and
not expose themselves to temptation you
know if you recognize your limitations
you're trying to not drink for a month
you don't spend as much time going into
pyres but the person who thinks yeah I
can go in I'll just have a coke but then
yes then they fail yeah well thank you
very much you know thanked thank you dan
guac for hosting us thank you reason for
holding this thank you and that's in the
sec